so our last story today women ruin
everything women ruin everything really
we've ruined the workforce with me to we
even ruin women's sports by whining and
complaining about her pay and now we're
ruining gyms yes ruining gyms there was
a woman that decided to make a skit of
how women are just ruining the gym let's
pull it up hi guys this is a tutorial on
how to make a guy look like a creep at
the gym first I like to set up the
barbell in the free weight area directly
in to my Victim wearing tiny shorts then
I start doing rdl's for him to see that
[__] fat and grab his attention I'll
then stop my workout turn around and
confront him about perving on me making
sure I'm getting all of this on camera
next I'll green screen my video and talk
about how I feel violated and then post
on my social media so I received
comments from other girls saying go sis
see you next time and so she's making
fun of this but she's right she's right
these women look at H they're half naked
in the
gym and they get mad when the men look a
imagine okay imagine if I was dressed up
as a police officer and I got mad when
people came up to me and said why are
you dressed like a police officer or sir
or sorry ma'am or ma'am ma'am please
help me I need help whatever it's like
well what did you expect dressed like
that the comments in the video really
are supporting this chick Walt says even
an old guy like me sees it at almost
every session in the gym now I never saw
10 to 15 years ago yeah it used to be
like weird to bring a camera even even
just five years ago I'm thinking nobody
really recorded their workouts like that
but now the cameras are coming in and I
was just about to say the segregated
gyms they can be as naked as they like
and men can work out in
peace yes I I think you're gonna I we
should start a male only gym because
really and truly it's like if you're
going to keep coming into the gym half
naked and then getting mad when men look
it's like men can't win they're like
okay I'm here to work out I'm going to
get my gym on and then boom all the
women come in and they're like oh look
at that they're half naked then the
women are like why are you looking at me
it's kind of weird to think about
because growing up in my generation yoga
pants are so normal like it's so normal
you know I mean we had spandex from a
super young age like you're 12 and
you're given spandex part of your
uniform for volleyball and it's kind of
weird to think about like how immodest
and not normal that is for the older
generation like yoga pants leggings I'll
hear people over the age of maybe 40
talk about it and they can't believe
that this is just normal for people to
wear and I remember being 18 I was in
Germany um because I grew up with
nannies from Germany so when I was 18 I
went to Germany and I lived with one for
the
summer and I remember I had a couple
pairs of leggings and it was like what
they looked at they were like what are
you wearing but it's super normal in the
US so it kind of begs the question of
like what is appropriate to wear at the
gym now it's just ridiculous it's like
women in sports bras and like boot like
it's just crazy you know it was kind of
like baggy t-shirts when I was in high
school you know it begs the question if
you're going to come to the gym half
naked can you really be mad if men look
there was another woman that I saw on
Twitter I think it's from a Tik Tok
account but on Twitter talking about how
she doesn't know what to do this woman
is so confused what does she do after
the gym she goes to the gym half naked
and then after she doesn't know what to
do let's pull it up it says wearing a
cute gym set is all fun and games until
you look like a complete [__] after at
the grocery
store are women this
stupid are we really this
dumb okay because all right again I'm a
volleyball player you wear fandex and
volleyball but everybody brings pants to
wear after I have such a simple
solution I have two solutions and I just
I I want to know if this is like real
okay but I'm I'm gonna be nice I'm gonna
be
nice all right option one you could wear
something else to the gym
ah I
know I know this is crazy no no but she
can't do that that's too she has her
matching gy said okay option
two the same way when you wear a
swimsuit to the beach you bring a cover
up you could you could wear sweats after
anyways just my two cents I guess don't
shoot the messenger um Elijah schaer
says female gym clothes are just
underwear oh
yeah oh yeah I'm a gym regular and I
waiting for the day they just start
working out in the nude not complaining
just noticing how the amount of clothing
warant seems to be getting less and less
yeah women go into any space that we
just get naked it's getting really
ridiculous like we go into they're
starting to get naked in church it's
like the audacity can you imagine and
and women fight for the oh my gosh
mothers will fight for the ability to be
naked they they'll get naked in front of
their children and then take pictures
and post it on the
internet women are like please please
please let me be naked oh please I need
to be naked
like what is wrong with you
people a secure person has their own
standards but never imposes upon others
maybe she should be more modest and not
surprised men tend to have have distaste
maybe others should simply have better
dignity and decency is isn't it isn't
that obscene it goes both ways I mean
you know what you know what's so
interesting as a chick I find it
distracting when these chicks are half
naked like I find it distracting it's
like I'm I'm trying to work out I find
it distracting I can't imagine what the
men think you know what I mean like it's
got to be so distracting with these
chicks just throwing their bodies in
their face and you know what else is sad
There are men that want to be faithful
to their girlfriends and their wives and
they can't go anywhere without all these
women throw in their nakedness please
please look at me naked it's
like anyway so you know now women have
also ruined the gym we live in this
delusional world where we tell women
we're more special and important than we
are all the time there's marketing and
propaganda 247 saying you're so
important you were so special you were
so amazing you were so smart we have an
entire school system dedicated to making
us think that we're smarter than we are
and I'm going to show you a clip that's
going to prove my point so there's a
woman that has a
PHD that was asked to take an IQ test
someone with a PhD you would think
that's the highest level of Education
you must be very intelligent to get that
right the school system doesn't favor
women right women are just very smart
productive members of society when they
go get educated let's let's show the
clip I'm 21 I'm a high school graduate
and I work in the Marine Corp I'm 30
years old I have my PhD in cancer
biology and I work in a Biotech Industry
grad school I went to University of
South Carolina and undergrad I went to
University of Florida 1 2 3 three four 5
6 to me I don't know PhD cancer biology
scientist I work in a biotech company we
make coid 19 testing kids stuff like
that and then six it has nothing to do
with your background I don't think you
really have the highest EQ out of all of
us Tyler he ranked less for me
personally because the way he carries
himself he was ranking intelligence
based on his point of view and not
taking in other people's point of views
so number one is Raymond number two
would be
kayy number three would be Tyler and
number four would be sha number five is
sea and number six is
[Music]
Maria there you have it folks a woman
imagine a woman thinking she's smarter
than she is why would she think that why
you know what's funny I remember the
time in life I have a little brother I
remember the day in my life when I
really Iz that my little brother was
smarter than me to this day I'll tell
you that um it
was I I remember because my little
brother would always like he's kind of
bossy my little my little brother he's
bossy guy and he would always boss me
around and I didn't want to listen to
him you don't want to listen to your
little brother and I remember one day we
used to fight when I was a kid and one
day I just realized that he was smarter
than me and I started listening to him I
realized he was right about most things
you know that was the day we got along
after that really and truly but now this
woman who's so smart does all this
testing is so amazing so then my
question is how did she make it through
school how does she have this job if
she's literally the least smart and the
lowest IQ and she's working at this big
Tech or whatever company my guess is
probably a man is doing most of the work
for her yes so savan says if there's one
thing I've learned it's usually that the
people who have medical degrees are some
of the dumbest and most ignorant Among
Us imagine spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars not even
questioning whether or not you should
understand basic nutrition and its
relation to the human body then spending
the rest of your life handing approved
big Pharma medication that doesn't
actually heal people yeah I remember
being in high school it's kind of a
weird lesson my dad taught me when I was
younger it's funny because when I was a
kid my dad um he he would tell me these
like little bits of wisdom I guess that
didn't make sense to me at the time time
or I thought he was just like old or
whatever at the time but then you get
older and a lot of stuff sort of starts
to make sense so an example of this was
one time when I was a kid I was really
struggling in math and like I remember
my dad would spend like hours with me
trying to teach me math and he would get
so frustrated because I just couldn't do
it I was so bad and um I remember it was
like after a game or something that I
had he was driving me home and he says
and I said to him like Dad you don't
understand with the school stuff you
don't get it you're so smart like you
just you would never understand because
my dad excelled really at school from a
young age like he went to the University
of Chicago which is like a really
prestigious University where I'm from
and I remember he told me he looked at
me and he said in life you know it's
really not about who's the smartest it's
about who works the hardest because you
know if you work hard for five 10 15 20
30 years it adds up and over time the
people that are born smart they just
can't comp compete and he told me that
in the second half of your life you
really see who worked hard and who was
just gifted from a young age um and he
also told me because I remember I would
I wanted to go to Notre Dame that was
like my dream school when I was in high
school I'm Irish so was like Irish
Catholic University and you know I I
would never have gotten in there so I
didn't even apply but like they wouldn't
have taken me and um my dad I remember
he would tell me that some of the
dumbest people he's ever met that in his
life have gone to Ivy League and
prestigious universities and he would
tell me that basically that stuff means
nothing it means absolutely nothing and
again I would say well that's easy for
you to say Dad you went to one you're so
smart and I get older and I I realize
how righty was because I I was telling
the story before I did the video one of
the smartest women that I ever knew um
she got like a 34 in her act which is if
you're not from from the Midwest that's
like ungodly High that's like nobody
gets that high on their acts she did and
she believed in the men are women and
women are men stuff like a woman that's
smart and it makes you question the
whole education system how are people
this idiotic getting this far in life
and in their careers and I would
hypothesize that many times women go
through life because men are doing the
work for them um and I think it's very
similar to the WNBA where the women
think they're doing so amazing and
awesome and really it's just charity
work the men are paying for everything
and instead of having gratitude for the
men they [__] on them as a thank you J X
hippie says the thing I have learned
over the years is that degrees show
nothing more than the ability to
continue to show up to a class and copy
quotes to write a paper it has nothing
to do at all with intelligence I have
been judged all my life for being
dyslexic yet my I my IQ is
136 I totally agree with that because
the thing is they switched the education
system it used to be just more
standardized tests you have a test day
every three months or whatever it was
and you're tested on the material but
they made the education system more
feminized um again men operate on a
hierarchy who was the highest IQ women
are more likely to operate more
egalitarian so everybody's special and
amazing and awesome so what did they do
they added
in participation trophies essentially
you show up and you get points just for
showing up to class being on time um
they add in all these papers these
assignments all of these little useless
kind of useless things that kind of prop
up your grade a little bit and I totally
benefited from it I look back to being
in school I totally did better on the
written stuff the assignments where both
of my brothers because I grew up between
two boys both both of my brothers they
really accelerated more in the testing
and I think a lot of men view all of the
little stuff as kind of useless like
they they don't see the point and this
is why a lot of parents are going to
homeschooling that's why you see this
huge rise in the number of people that
are homeschooled because the faith in
the education system is is going going
downhill jail says you can tell the
contempt that they have for each other
she shows her contempt without restraint
because she has been taught that her
feelings are right while he has contempt
for her but he is hiding it behind a
smile because it's not proper he was
brought up right she wasn't yeah and I
think that's true you know so many times
women have really lost like decency you
know just because you feel a certain way
about someone it doesn't really matter
you're still meant to be polite you're
still meant to smile and be nice to them
and I really hate this new culture that
we have we're saying that's somehow fake
or that they're fake whatever when
really it's just being a decent and
polite human being and we've sort of
lost that in society like especially
when I came to London that was like a
big I'm from the Midwest and I hated
London for the first year I remember I
had like something that I in the
beginning I just started saying hi to
people randomly and people would look at
me like I was crazy they would look at
me like I was insane because it's just
not people just aren't as friendly here
like they are in the Midwest and really
the older I get the less friendly I see
people becoming Maggie Rock says the
full video is hard to watch I actually
feel like the military guy's definition
of intelligence was probably the most
accurate but more than half of them
started laughing when the ones said I
don't place a lot of value on the
military who said they don't place a lot
of value on the
military like
[__] and again you know this is why I
get older and I start to realize the
things that my dad said were right
there's a lot of people that act like
they're smarter than they are and it's
funny one tell te sign that I can tell
that someone isn't as smart as they are
is that they're always talking about how
smart they are because if you're really
that smart you you don't even have to
tell anybody that you just people can
just get gather that from you like the
smartest people like you never see
Jordan Peterson saying oh I am so smart
and amazing and awesome you just hear
him talk and you realize he's a really
knowledgeable guy